your obsession with comedy or your
interest in comedy goes way back to when
you were a kid and you got to do
something that I dreamed of doing but
never got to do which is you got to go
to a live taping of Johnny Carson's
Tonight Show oh yeah and that's
something I never experienced can you
tell me what that was like yes I was I
was 13 I had just been barn mitzvot and
my brother Max had gone to Spring Break
and been bumped three times uh and back
then in the 19 from the from the
audience from the no I'm sorry that made
it sound like my brother Max was a guest
on on the night show with Carson no he'd
been bumped by the airline oh I see okay
flying on spring break and and so he had
gotten these these uh tickets they were
they I don't know if they were round
trip but they afforded my mother and I
to go to Los Angeles my brother couldn't
use them because he was starting a job
in Florida so he gave him to us we use
them to go to Los Angeles stayed with my
cousin Dela we waited in line and got
tickets to get into but I was 13 you had
to be 16 to get into a live taping but I
was already 5'11 or almost six feet
right and so my mother said he's 16 and
then I got in and um I said oh my God we
made it and then an usher said excuse me
how old are you and my mother got right
in her face and she said do you think I
would take a a a child into something as
important as The Tonight Show with
Johnny Carson and and my mother I mean
the lying godess yeah she really got
your job be great if she got her got
that kid fired and ruined her life so
convincing I felt like I was 16 I was I
had just turned 13 and anyhow it
couldn't have been a better first of all
Johnny did the monologue and he screwed
up one of the lines and retook it and
then when they went to break he said I
really blew the out of that joke
and I said oh my gosh he swore yeah and
you could you didn't hear Johnny Carson
you know what I talked to Robert Smigel
told me that he went to a taping of
Johnny Carson and Johnny Carson when he
knew it wouldn't cuz it was pre-taped
yeah said in front of the crowd and
they went wild wow so that I think that
was something he liked to do because
everyone thought oh back then the idea
of someone that you knew on TV that
intimately saying the word was
impossible yes and and so that must have
been electrifying it was electrifying
and then the guest was Carrie fiser and
Gary shanon oh my God yeah so so
Princess Leia at her
and then and then this and Gary at his
chandling oh my gosh and then this
comedian who I only knew from The
Tonight Show and he was so funny and
then he did this bit with it wasn't a
bit I guess but it came off as a bit
with Carrie Fisher where he says uh I
know your parents um uh Debbie Reynolds
and and Eddie fiser do you know my
parents M uh Irv and Muriel Shandling
and oh my and I was in love I was like
here's this guy who's who's Jewish
neurotic and miserable yet he's flirting
with Carrie fiser and it was that that
was the thing that I always found so
interesting about comedians they they
really had nothing to speak of in terms
of being attractive to to women but all
this confidence and it and it just it
really captured me at a very very young
age I was like that is the only way I'm
ever going to get married is if I'm
super funny like Shandling or or
somebody like that that's fascinating
because I
realiz you know I I've always I've
talked about this a lot but I always I
think that kids
naturally uh well I'm G to back it up
because I think this is the analogy I've
made but I think when you when you play
a video game you're told here are your
powers or here are your weapons you get
like an inventory yeah and I think all
kids throughout history take an
inventory early on and I remember my
feeling as a kid for me was what what
are all the necessary things I need and
not having them like do I have the looks
that a grow no do I have am I an athlete
no am I this am I not and and I just
remember kept going through and then
when I found out that I could make
people laugh thinking all right I've got
this I'm going to develop the out
of yes I'm GNA yes and uh then being
able to you know and and mostly being
interested in I want that girl to like
me so yeah and then the big barrier is
she's laughing really hard but I see her
going to the dance with that other guy
oh yeah yeah yeah he not as funny he's
not or his comedy is is is not as well
worked out right right exactly no he has
no comedy but he has a developed body
yeah who needs that yeah my shallow
chest should be enough for anyone and I
my waisted legs what's wrong with
these my 19th century
cough the little bits of pink pink foam
from dissolving
lung what's wrong with that why are you
saying those things
though my dad took care of everyone but
me a brilliant scientist who never
noticed that I was dying of
consumption you were the control experim
that was a control
experiment I oh my God I think
consumption is my favorite
old timey disease because a lot of
people will go tuberculosis but the
people who are familiar go consumption
consumption
also I love um what it's true oh it's
totally I'm totally with Gary on look
you and I speak the exact same
language I like that people used to have
stuff called the flux yeah yeah yeah
yeah or they'd call you a lunger you had
if you if you had a l if you had
consumption they call you a lunger yeah
also I love um that when you get got
sick back then they would apply a pus
they would apply a mustard pus to your
chest which basically means you know
just covering your chest with mustard
VAP yeah exactly but but they did it for
like someone get shot in the head I
believe when Lincoln was dying of a
bullet the size of an Oreo cookie in his
brain they were like apply a
pus I'm mustard pus will save the
president did it work kind of cuz when
he died he smelled like a hot
dog and people weren't quite as sad
there were I'm sure there were other
puses there was there was the mustard
about mustard the
remade the toad
F that way he doesn't pull through but
we have a dip we dipping sauce at the
endis after after after Lincoln died
everyone sat around and they were very
sad and seart seart said now he belongs
to the ages and then somehow someone
produced a bag of tortilla chips and
they just started dipping into his this
stuff little salsa they all just start
crunching God what Mary Lincoln comes in
what are you doing well we can't let
this go to
waste the coffin isn't here
yet